Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
WHY IS IT WORTH $5 MILLION?
WE DID $1.1 MILLION IN REVENUE.
WOW.
WELL,
YOU JUST SHUT ME UP.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
WOW!
Narrator: ...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
TELL US ABOUT THE FLAXSEED
AND THE IMPACT.
I ONLY TELL THAT
TO MY BUSINESS PARTNERS.
[ LAUGHS ]
ALL RIGHT.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
$250,000 FOR 35%.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
AN OFFER.
WHAT IF I GAVE YOU
$250,000 FOR 30%?
YOU WANT TO STEP OVER DOLLARS TO
SAVE PENNIES, THAT'S UP TO YOU.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
NO WAY IN HELL IT'S WORTH
5 MILLION BUCKS.
SIR, YOU'RE WEARING A SUIT.
I'M SELLING T-SHIRTS.
I WEAR T-SHIRTS
ALL WEEKEND LONG.
IT DOESN'T MEAN
YOU PLAY IN THE CIRCLE.
John: [ Chuckling ] OH.
OH!
HE JUST DISSED YOU.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
I AM MIKAILA.
AND I AM HER DAD, THEO.
I'M 9 YEARS OLD,
AND I'VE HAD MY BUSINESS
FOR OVER HALF OF MY LIFE.
MIKAILA'S ALWAYS LOVED
BUSINESS.
EVER SINCE
SHE WAS 4 YEARS OLD,
WE NOTICED THAT SHE WAS
A NATURAL ENTREPRENEUR.
AH, THERE YOU GO.
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER,
ME AND MY BROTHER, JACOB,
WOULD SET UP A STAND
AND SELL LEMONADE,
ARTS AND CRAFTS,
PAINTED ROCKS.
ANYTHING THAT WE COULD
MAKE OURSELVES,
WE WOULD SELL IT.
ONE PRODUCT
WAS A TOP SELLER,
AND I KNEW WE COULD MAKE THAT
A REAL BUSINESS,
SO I ASKED MY PARENTS
FOR HELP,
AND THAT'S HOW MY BUSINESS
WAS BORN.
WHAT'S THE UPDATE ON FINANCE?
NOW EVERYONE IN MY FAMILY
WORKS FOR MY COMPANY.
RUNNING A BUSINESS
ISN'T EASY.
BETWEEN GOING TO SCHOOL
AND WORKING ON BUSINESS,
I'M AS BUSY AS A BEE.
HERE'S YOUR ORDER.
Woman: THANK YOU.
ENJOY.
I KNOW THE SHARKS
ARE GONNA LOVE MY PRODUCT,
AND I HOPE THEY GIVE ME
A REALLY SWEET DEAL.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S MIKAILA ULMER.
AND I'M THEO ULMER,
MIKAILA'S DAD.
I'M THE OWNER OF
BeeSweet LEMONADE,
AND TODAY,
I'M HERE TO ASK FOR
$60,000 FOR 10% EQUITY
IN MY COMPANY.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME
YOU TRIED SOMETHING
SO GOOD AND REFRESHING
AND WONDERED,
"COULD THIS BE GOOD FOR ME?"
WELL, SHARKS, GUESS WHAT?
I CREATED A PRODUCT
THAT IS BOTH GOOD FOR YOU
AND TASTES GREAT
AT THE SAME TIME.
MY PRODUCT IS LEMONADE,
BUT NOT JUST ANY LEMONADE --
HONEYBEE SWEETENED
LEMONADE
WITH A VERY SPECIAL
INGREDIENT -- FLAXSEED.
WHEN I WAS IN KINDERGARTEN --
YES, 4√ YEARS OLD --
I SIGNED UP IN THE YOUTH
ENTREPRENEURSHIP CONTEST.
WHILE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT PRODUCT TO CREATE,
TWO BIG EVENTS HAPPENED --
I GOT STUNG BY TWO BEES
IN ONE WEEK,
AND MY GREAT-GRANNY HELEN
SENT ME A 1940s COOKBOOK
WITH HER FAVORITE RECIPE
OF FLAXSEED LEMONADE IN IT.
I DIDN'T ENJOY THE BEE STINGS
AT ALL,
BUT I BECAME FASCINATED
WITH BEES
AND WHAT THEY DO
IN OUR ECOSYSTEM,
THAT I DECIDED TO CREATE
A PRODUCT
THAT HELPS SAVE THE BEES
AND USES MY GREAT-GRANNY HELEN'S
RECIPE, AS WELL,
AND THAT'S HOW BeeSweet
WAS BORN.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE
FOUR FLAVORS --
THE ORIGINAL MINT, HALF-AND-HALF
TEA AND LEMONADE,
GINGER,
AND ALSO PRICKLY PEAR.
OUR SIMPLE INGREDIENTS
HAVE ADDED HEALTH BENEFITS
TO PROVIDE A FUNCTIONAL,
FLAVORFUL TWIST.
BeeSweet LEMONADE OFFERS
THE CONSUMER
A HEALTHIER
BEVERAGE ALTERNATIVE.
SO, SHARKS, WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE SWEET, JOIN MY TEAM,
AND HELP ME BUILD
MY AMERICAN DREAM?
LEMONADE, ANYONE?
ABSOLUTELY!
[ CHUCKLES ]
BRING IT ON,
MIKAILA.
SO CUTE.
WHAT FLAVOR IS THIS,
MIKAILA?
THIS IS GINGER.
THAT'S HALF AND HALF
TEA AND LEMONADE.
Herjavec: IT'S GREAT.
Theo:
HE GETS THE ORIGINAL.
Mikaila:
AND THIS IS THE ORIGINAL.
THE ORIGINAL!
THANKS, GUYS.
IT'S GOOD.
HOW OLD ARE YOU?
I'M 9 YEARS OLD.
9 YEARS OLD?
I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
REALLY? WOW.
YOU REALLY ARE POISED
AND HANDLE YOURSELF GREAT.
WOW.
TELL US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE BUSINESS.
ARE YOU SELLING?
WE'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS
ACTUALLY
FOR FIVE AND A HALF YEARS,
AND, UH, YEAR TO DATE,
WE'VE GOT $25,000
IN ACTUAL SALES THROUGH AUGUST.
WHERE ARE YOU SELLING
THE PRODUCT?
WHOLE FOODS MARKET.
Greiner: GREAT.
WE'RE CURRENTLY SOLD IN OVER
30 LOCATIONS IN FOUR CITIES,
BUT WE RECENTLY RECEIVED
AN OPPORTUNITY
TO EXPAND WITHIN
THE ENTIRE SOUTHWEST REGION,
WHICH COVERS
FOUR STATES.
TELL US ABOUT THE FLAXSEED
AND THE IMPACT.
WELL, I CAN'T TELL
HOW I GET THE FLAXSEED IN THERE,
BECAUSE IT'S MY
GREAT-GRANNY HELEN'S
TRADE SECRET.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I ONLY TELL THAT
TO MY BUSINESS PARTNERS.
Cuban: [ LAUGHS ]
SMART GIRL!
SMART GIRL.
THAT IS AWESOME
RIGHT THERE.
WHAT'S THE --
WHAT'S THE BENEFIT TO IT?
WELL, FLAXSEED IS A SEED
PACKED WITH OMEGAS AND FIBER.
IT KEEPS YOU GOING.
THEO, WE KNOW
ABOUT MIKAILA'S BACKGROUND,
AND SHE'S HIGHLY QUALIFIED.
Theo: RIGHT.
TELL US ABOUT YOUR BACKGROUND.
SO, BETWEEN MY WIFE
AND I,
WE'VE GOT OVER 40 YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE
IN MARKETING, OPERATIONS,
AND FINANCE.
ARE YOU FULL-TIME AT THIS?
MY WIFE'S ACTUALLY FULL-TIME
WITH IT RIGHT NOW,
AND, UH, THIS IS MY SECOND
FULL-TIME JOB, SO --
THEO, WHERE DID YOU WORK
BEFORE THIS?
I WORKED AT XEROX,
AND I ALSO WORKED
AT DELL COMPUTER.
WHAT ARE THE PLANS
FOR THE $60,000?
WHAT I'M GONNA DO
WITH THE $60,000 IS
I'M GONNA MAKE MORE PRODUCT
SO I CAN LAUNCH
INTO THE WHOLE SOUTHWEST REGION.
WHERE DO YOU
MANUFACTURE THIS TODAY?
WELL,
IT'S IN AUSTIN, TEXAS.
WE HAVE A LOCAL CO-PACKER
WHO MANUFACTURES IT FOR US.
HOW MUCH DO YOU CHARGE FOR IT
AT RETAIL?
BETWEEN $2.75 AND $3.00.
AND WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE IT, MIKAILA?
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE IT?
$1.50.
MIKAILA, WHAT'S YOUR
BIGGEST CHALLENGE
IN YOUR BUSINESS RIGHT NOW?
UM, IT'S PROBABLY FITTING SCHOOL
AND BeeSweet LEMONADE
AND ALL THE OTHER ACTIVITIES
THAT I MIGHT WANT TO DO --
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT.
SCHOOL HAS GOT TO GO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
DOES IT CONCERN YOU THAT
YOU ONLY HAVE $25,000 IN SALES
AFTER FIVE AND A HALF YEARS?
NO. NO, NOT -- NOT REALLY,
BECAUSE THAT'S --
IT CONCERNS ME.
THAT'S NOT
A TOTAL IN SALES.
THIS YEAR TO DATE.
CORRECT?
CORRECT.
WE JUST STARTED
IN WHOLE FOODS
IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR
WITH ONE STORE,
AND EACH MONTH,
WE'VE GROWN.
WOW.
DO YOU FIND $3.00 IS
A PREMIUM PRICE FOR LEMONADE?
'CAUSE I FIND IT EXPENSIVE.
$2.99 IS A LOT
FOR A JAR OF LEMONADE.
WELL, IF WE'RE ABLE
TO SCALE THE BUSINESS,
YOU KNOW, WE CAN, UH, LOOK AT
SOME SORT OF PRICE ADJUSTMENT.
WHAT CAN YOU GET
THE PRICE DOWN TO?
WE CAN GET THE COST
DOWN BELOW $1.00.
HOW MANY UNITS
WOULD YOU HAVE TO BUY
TO GET THAT COST DOWN TO THAT?
WE -- WE WOULD NEED TO PRODUCE
AROUND 2,700 BOTTLES.
GOTCHA.
SO, WHEN YOU GO INTO
THE SOUTHWEST REGION...
MM-HMM.
...WOULD YOU THEN HAVE AN ORDER
FOR 2,700 BOTTLES?
WE BELIEVE
BY THE SECOND QUARTER,
WE WILL HAVE ENOUGH VOLUME
TO GET US TO 3,000 GALLONS
PER SKU,
AND THEN WE CAN LOWER THAT COST.
GUYS, I LOOK AT THIS AS
A VERY COMPETITIVE MARKET.
NOT TO SAY THAT MIKAILA
ISN'T FANTASTIC.
THE GUTS TO COME IN HERE
AND PITCH US --
THAT TAKES A LOT.
BUT YOU'RE NOT COMMITTED,
MIKAILA.
YOU'RE NOT WILLING
TO DROP OUT OF SCHOOL.
[ LAUGHS ]
SO I HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THAT.
AND I WANT MY C.E.O. FULL TIME,
SO COME BACK
WHEN YOU'RE ACTUALLY READY
TO SAY, "SCHOOL'S OUT FOREVER,"
AND WE'LL TALK.
UNTIL THEN, I'M OUT.
MIKAILA, WE SEE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PRODUCTS ON THE SHOW.
SOME THINGS ARE MORE COMPETITIVE
THAN OTHERS.
THE DRINK MARKET LIKE THIS
AT A STORE LEVEL,
IT'S VERY, VERY DIFFICULT
BECAUSE IT COMES DOWN TO BRAND
AND SHELF SPACE,
WHICH IS DIFFERENT
THAN NECESSARILY
THE QUALITY OF THE PRODUCT.
SO, FOR ME, IT'S JUST
A REALLY TOUGH MARKET.
I-I'M OUT.
SO, A COUPLE OF THINGS --
UM, YOU MENTIONED
COM-- COMMITMENT,
AND YOU MENTIONED
SHELF SPACE.
FIRST, SHE STARTED THIS
WHEN SHE WAS 4√ YEARS OLD.
[ CHUCKLES ]
AND SHE'S BEEN DOING IT
FOR FIVE YEARS.
SO, OVER HALF HER LIFE,
SHE'S BEEN SELLING LEMONADE.
SO I-I-I WOULD DISAGREE
THAT, UH,
THERE'S A LACK OF COMMITMENT.
EVEN THOUGH SHE'S NOT WILLING
TO DROP OUT OF SCHOOL YET,
SHE'S VERY MUCH COMMITTED.
Cuban: [ LAUGHS ]
YEAH, I DON'T THINK
IT'S A QUESTION OF COMMITMENT.
FOR FIVE YEARS.
DEFINITELY COMMITTED,
AND AS FAR AS --
YOU CAN'T TAKE
HIS QUESTION SERIOUSLY.
YEAH.
YES, YOU CAN.
I'M DEAD SERIOUS.
AS FAR AS SHELF SPACE --
NO. YOU CAN'T.
WE'VE ALREADY --
WE'VE ALREADY GOT
THE SHELF SPACE,
AND WE'VE GOT
AN OPPORTUNITY --
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, THEO,
YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN -- MIKAILA,
YOU'RE AMAZING, RIGHT?
I MEAN,
Y-YOU'RE INCREDIBLE.
BUT THE CHALLENGE IS,
YOU'RE NOT QUITE A COMPANY YET.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY TO ME,
WHILE THIS IS A GREAT START,
I DON'T THINK THIS IS THE BEST
THAT MIKAILA'S GOING TO DO.
I JUST THINK THAT THERE'S
SO MUCH BETTER AHEAD FOR HER,
SO COME BACK, YOU KNOW,
WHEN YOU GRADUATE
FROM MIDDLE SCHOOL.
YOU'LL PROBABLY OWN
HALF THE PLACE.
UM, BUT WE WANT
TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
BUT FOR RIGHT NOW,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
WELL, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
Greiner: YOU KNOW, MIKAILA,
I'VE BEEN KNOWN TO SAY OFTEN
I CAN TELL
IF SOMETHING OR SOMEONE
IS A HERO OR A ZERO.
HERO OR A ZERO.
YOU ARE DEFINITELY A BIG HERO.
I THINK YOU'RE DOING
EVERY SINGLE THING RIGHT,
AND YOU'VE COME IN
WITH WHAT I THINK
IS ONE OF THE BEST LOGOS
I'VE EVER SEEN FOR LEMONADE.
IT'S AMAZING.
THANK YOU.
I HAVE STRUGGLE HERE,
BECAUSE I CAN'T DRINK LEMONADE.
I AM ALLERGIC.
SO, I COULDN'T TRY IT.
SO, FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
WELL,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ONE SHARK LEFT.
DAYMOND.
Narrator:
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
DAYMOND IS THEO AND MIKAILA'S
LAST CHANCE AT A DEAL
FOR THEIR COMPANY,
BeeSweet LEMONADE.
ONE SHARK LEFT.
DAYMOND.
MY BIGGEST CHALLENGE IS
I DON'T KNOW THE SPACE.
BUT I JUST DID A DEAL
WITH A COMPANY CALLED HLA
OUT ON THE EAST COAST.
THEY'RE A DISTRIBUTOR
TO ALL THE "C" STORES --
"C" STANDS FOR
"CONVENIENCE."
CONVENIENCE STORES,
BASICALLY.
SO, I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
AN OFFER,
AND THE OFFER IS THIS --
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $60,000
FOR 25%...
...CONTINGENT THAT
MY PARTNERS ON THE EAST COAST
THAT DISTRIBUTE TO "C" STORES,
CONVENIENCE STORES,
WILL BE ABLE TO GET THAT
IN THE STORES.
IF THEY CANNOT GET IT IN,
WE DON'T HAVE A DEAL.
AND THE REASON I NEED 25% IS
I'M GONNA HAVE TO SPLIT
THIS PARTNERSHIP UP ON MY SIDE.
DAYMOND HAS MADE YOU AN OFFER.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
IT'S A DEAL.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
ALL RIGHT.
Greiner:
CONGRATULATIONS!
CONGRATS, GUYS.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU!
CONGRATS, MIKAILA!
THANK YOU.
Greiner: CONGRATS!
NICE JOB.
YOU DID A WONDERFUL JOB.
UM, I'M REALLY EXCITED
THAT DAYMOND'S MY NEW PARTNER,
AND I THINK THAT HE'LL BE
A GREAT MATCH
FOR BeeSweet LEMONADE.
Corcoran:
IT'S THAT TIME OF YEAR AGAIN,
AND I'VE DECIDED TO INVITE
MY MOST SUCCESSFUL ENTREPRENEURS
TO MY HOUSE IN UTAH.
WELCOME TO THE MOUNTAINS!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THIS YEAR, I'VE INVITED
GRACE AND LACE, PIP SNACKS,
VILLY CUSTOM, RY'S RUFFERY,
DAISY CAKES, CEREBRAL SUCCESS,
AND, OF COURSE,
COUSINS MAINE LOBSTER.
BEFORE "SHARK TANK,"
TOTAL SALES
FOR ALL SEVEN BUSINESS
WERE ABOUT $2 MILLION.
SINCE MAKING A DEAL WITH ME
ON "SHARK TANK,"
TOTAL SALES
ARE OVER $24 MILLION.
WE'RE HERE TO SHARE
OUR TRADE SECRETS,
AND WE'RE ALL GONNA GO HOME
A HECK OF A LOT SMARTER.
I LIKE MY ENTREPRENEURS
TO SHARE THEIR HIGHS AND LOWS,
FIGURE OUT WHICH STRATEGIES
WORKED AND WHICH ONES DIDN'T
AND COLLECTIVELY BECOME
STRONGER BUSINESSES.
HAVING THE CO-PACKER HAS
HELPED US SPEND MORE TIME
FIGURING OUT
HOW TO GROW THE BUSINESS.
WHETHER IT'S
THE WEB DEVELOPMENT TEAM
OR SEARCH ENGINE OPTIMIZATION,
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT EVERYONE KNOWS
THAT YOU EXIST.
YOU GUYS GAVE US
A TON OF INSIGHT.
IT'S ALWAYS NICE TO BE PART OF
A FAMILY LIKE THIS.
EVERYBODY CARES
ABOUT EVERYBODY,
AND IT'S BECAUSE
IT STARTS WITH BARBARA.
IT'S SO INSPIRING.
IT'S ALL BECAUSE OF
ONE PERSON'S VISION.
Corcoran: THIS RETREAT
IS ALL ABOUT SHARING IDEAS,
BUT MY FAVORITE PART IS
SOME FUN ON THE SLOPES.
READY TO GO SKIING?
[ ALL CHEER ]
Tselikis:
IT'S BEEN 2√ YEARS SINCE BARBARA
CAME INTO OUR LIVES,
AND WE'RE NOW AT $6.5 MILLION
IN SALES.
Hiltbrand:
BARBARA SET UP A MEETING
WITH GNC WITH ONE PHONE CALL.
NOW WE'RE LAUNCHING
IN 1,100 GNC STORES,
AND I COULDN'T BE MORE STOKED.
Nelson: TO THINK THAT MY MOTHER
AND I WENT FROM $27,000
TO NOW $3.1 MILLION
HAS REALLY BEEN LIFE-CHANGING.
Hinnant: BEFORE "SHARK TANK,"
WE HAD OVER $1 MILLION IN SALES,
AND NOW WE'VE GROSSED
OVER $10.5 MILLION IN SALES.
TO MY FAMILY.
CHEERS!
I'VE BEEN AN ENTREPRENEUR
ALL MY LIFE,
AND I BUILT A BUSINESS WITHOUT
THE HELP OF OTHER ENTREPRENEURS.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
MY DREAM COME TRUE
TO SURROUND MYSELF
WITH OTHER SMART PEOPLE
BUILDING THEIR OWN BUSINESS.
[ WOMAN SCREAMS, LAUGHS ]
THAT'S WHAT I'M DOING
FOR THIS FAMILY.
I WANT EVERYBODY
TO SUPPORT EACH OTHER,
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT,
EVERYBODY'S GONNA HAVE
THEIR DREAM COME TRUE.
I'M SURE OF IT.
Together:
THANK YOU, BARBARA!
WHOO!
Man: WHOO!
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK IS A RESOURCE
TO HELP CONTROL YOUR REPUTATION
IN THE AGE OF TECHNOLOGY.
HI, SHARKS.
I'M PATRICK AMBRON
FROM NEW YORK, NEW YORK,
AND MY COMPANY IS BrandYourself.
I'M SEEKING
A $2 MILLION INVESTMENT
IN EXCHANGE FOR A 13.5%
EQUITY STAKE...
John: [ LAUGHS ]
...IN MY COMPANY.
OH, WOW!
NICE!
SHARKS...
MEET BOB.
BOB WENT
TO AN IVY LEAGUE SCHOOL,
GRADUATED TOP OF HIS CLASS,
AND WAS EVEN PRESIDENT
OF THE DEBATE TEAM.
BOB WAS AN EMPLOYER'S DREAM,
BUT WHEN EMPLOYERS
LOOKED BOB UP ONLINE,
THEY DON'T MEET 4.0 BOB.
THEY MEET SPRING BREAK '08 BOB.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND BOB'S ONE MISTAKE
HAS BEEN COSTING HIM...
OH, MY GOD.
OH, BOB.
...DOZENS OF JOBS.
AN ONLINE SEARCH
IS NOW YOUR FIRST IMPRESSION,
AND BrandYourself HELPS ENSURE
YOU MAKE A GOOD ONE.
IT'S THE FIRST ONLINE PLATFORM
THAT HELPS PEOPLE IMPROVE
WHAT SHOWS UP
WHEN SOMEONE SEARCHES FOR THEM
ONLINE.
SO, IF AN EMPLOYER, A CLIENT,
A COLLEAGUE,
OR EVEN A DATE LOOKS THEM UP,
THEY WON'T FIND THAT
EMBARRASSING BLOG FROM COLLEGE.
INSTEAD, THEY'LL FIND
WHAT YOU WANT THEM TO FIND --
ACCURATE, RELEVANT RESULTS
ABOUT YOU.
OUR ONLINE PLATFORM IS SIMPLE.
YOU SIGN UP FOR AN ACCOUNT
AND ENTER YOUR NAME
TO GET YOUR SEARCH RESULTS.
YOU MARK THOSE RESULTS
AS EITHER POSITIVE, IRRELEVANT,
OR NEGATIVE TO GET A SCORE,
WHICH IS BASED ON
HOW GOOD YOU CURRENTLY LOOK
WHEN SOMEONE LOOKS YOU UP.
IN THIS CASE, IT LOOKS LIKE
WE COULD USE SOME HELP.
SO NEXT,
YOU SUBMIT THE RELEVANT THINGS
YOU THINK
PEOPLE SHOULD BE FINDING.
YOUR PERSONAL WEBSITE,
AN ARTICLE YOU WROTE --
ANYTHING.
OUR SOFTWARE ANALYZES THAT
AND SHOWS YOU ALL THE STEPS
YOU CAN TAKE THAT YOU HAVEN'T
THAT WILL MAKE IT
MORE SEARCH-ENGINE FRIENDLY
AND THEREFORE RANK HIGHER
FOR YOUR NAME.
NOW, YOU REPEAT THIS PROCESS
UNTIL YOUR FIRST PAGE IS FILLED
WITH RELEVANT RESULTS,
AND IRRELEVANT OR UNWANTED
RESULTS ARE BURIED FAR BELOW.
NOW, THIS IS THE SAME PROCESS
YOU USED TO HAVE TO PAY A FIRM
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
A YEAR TO DO FOR YOU.
BUT TODAY, EVERYBODY NEEDS
THE POWER AND THE TOOLS
TO PUT THEM BACK IN CONTROL
OF THEIR OWN ONLINE REPUTATIONS,
AND BrandYourself
IS THE COMPANY CREATING THOSE.
SO, SHARKS,
WHO WANTS TO JOIN US?
HOW DO YOU MAKE MONEY?
WE WANTED TO START OFF
WITH A FREE PRODUCT
SO PEOPLE WOULD COME IN
AND -- AND HELP THEMSELVES,
AND THEN A VERY INEXPENSIVE
PREMIUM VERSION,
WHICH IS STILL
ABOUT 100 BUCKS A YEAR.
OUR FREE PRODUCT
WAS ALSO BRINGING IN
PEOPLE WHO TRADITIONALLY WENT
TO OUR COMPETITORS --
HIGH-LEVEL EXECUTIVES
OR PEOPLE WITH
MORE COMPLICATED PROBLEMS --
AND WE LAUNCHED
A CONCIERGE SERVICE
FOR PEOPLE WHO NEED THAT.
HOW MANY PEOPLE SIGNED UP?
WE HAVE 300,000 FREE USERS,
OVER 5,000 SUBSCRIBERS,
AND CONCIERGE, WHICH IS NEW,
WHICH IS ABOUT A YEAR OLD,
UH, A LITTLE -- AROUND 500.
SO, CONCIERGE GETS YOU
AN ACTIVE HUMAN BEING...
YEP. A TEAM.
...WHO IS WORKING
WITH YOU --
YEAH. MM-HMM.
A TEAM OF PEOPLE.
WHAT'S THE PRICE
FOR THE CONCIERGE SERVICE?
THE AVERAGE FIRST-YEAR CONTRACT
IS ABOUT $5,000.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
SO, SINCE MARCH OF 2012,
WE'VE DONE, UH, $2.2 MILLION
WITH ANOTHER $500,000
IN BOOKED CONTRACTS.
OH.
OH, WOW.
BUT THE GROWTH
IS EVEN CRAZIER.
OKAY.
SO, $400,000 OUR FIRST YEAR.
100% GROWTH THE NEXT YEAR
TO $800,000.
THIS YEAR, WE'VE ALREADY
SURPASSED WHAT WE DID LAST YEAR.
WE'RE ON PACE PROBABLY
TO BREAK OVER $2 MILLION.
WHAT DO YOU DO
ABOUT SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS
THAT DON'T MAKE IT
INTO GOOGLE?
THAT'S A SEPARATE TOOL SET
WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT'S, YOU KNOW,
UNDER THE UMBRELLA
OF THE BUSINESS --
YOU DON'T HAVE THAT TODAY.
UH, WE DON'T HAVE IT
LAUNCHED TODAY, NO.
I CAN BUY THAT, AND I HAVE,
FOR $10,000 TO $15,000, OKAY?
MM-HMM.
CONCIERGE SERVICE
THAT IS WORKING THEIR WAY
THROUGH THE ISSUES
AROUND THESE BUSINESSES.
SURE.
AND SOMETIMES
IT DOESN'T WORK AT ALL.
YOU'RE RIGHT
IN THE SENSE NO MATTER WHAT,
THERE'S NO GUARANTEED RESULT.
SO YOU'RE
THE LOW-COST PROVIDER
IN AN INDUSTRY THAT ALREADY HAS
FOUR OR FIVE COMPETITORS.
IT'S NOT JUST A PRICE.
IT'S ACTUALLY THE SERVICE.
THERE'S A REASON WHY
THE BIG GUYS TRASH-TALK US.
THEY HATE US BECAUSE WE'RE
TAKING ALL THEIR CUSTOMERS
'CAUSE WE DO IT BETTER.
UH, WE'RE THE BEST COMPANY
IN THIS INDUSTRY.
WE'VE GOT THE BEST PEOPLE,
THE BEST TECHNOLOGY.
YEAH, BUT, PAT,
YOU KNOW, HERE'S THE PROBLEM --
BETTER IS NOT
A DIFFERENTIATOR.
YOU MAY BE SMARTER, FASTER,
LEANER, MEANER,
AND HAVE A BETTER MODEL,
BUT, YOU KNOW, YOUR VALUATION
IS 15 MILLION BUCKS.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYTHING
WRONG WITH YOUR BUSINESS.
I DON'T THINK I WOULD PAY
A $15 MILLION VALUATION FOR IT.
BUT, UM, YOU KNOW, YOU MIGHT
GET A CUSTOMER OUT OF IT,
AND I HOPE YOUR CLAIMS
ARE RIGHT.
I HOPE YOU DO
GET A CUSTOMER OUT OF IT
BECAUSE I'M TELLING YOU,
YOU'RE PAYING TOO MUCH,
AND WE'LL DO A MUCH BETTER JOB.
I'M OUT.
SO, I THINK THIS IS VALUABLE,
IT'S MUCH NEEDED,
BECAUSE WHEN PEOPLE COME
TO WORK FOR ME,
WE JUST LOOK 'EM UP.
RIGHT?
YEP.
THAT'S THE GOOD NEWS.
HERE'S THE BAD NEWS.
I JUST DON'T KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT THE SPACE
TO RISK $2 MILLION
OF MY OWN MONEY.
I'M OUT.
WELL, THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I APPRECIATE IT.
SO, THE VALUATION IS OBVIOUSLY
PROBABLY GOING TO BE AN ISSUE,
RIGHT?
MM-HMM.
I-I-I UNDERSTAND I'M ASKING --
PATRICK, IT'S AN ISSUE.
PART OF THE REASON --
JUST SO YOU GUYS
ARE ON THE SAME PAGE AS ME --
IS WE ACTUALLY
JUST RECENTLY RAISED
PART OF A ROUND
AT THIS VALUATION.
SO PART OF IT IS THE FAIRNESS.
THIS IS WHAT THE MARKET'S
PRICING AT.
HOW MUCH DID YOU RAISE?
WE RAISED --
WE WERE OUT RAISING $5 MILLION.
WE CLOSED $3 MILLION AND WANTED
TO LEAVE THE EXTRA $2 MILLION --
SO YOU CLOSED
$3 MILLION...
YES.
...AT ROUGHLY
A $15 MILLION VALUATION.
UH, YES.
WELL, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE A HUSTLER.
I LIKE THAT.
THANK YOU.
I HEAR THE ADS ALL THE TIME
FOR WHAT WE KEEP SAYING IS
YOUR MAJOR COMPETITION.
THEY ARE SPENDING MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ON ADVERTISING.
WHILE I THINK
IT'S A GREAT CONCEPT,
I THINK THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO SPEND MILLIONS
IN ADVERTISING
TO BE ABLE TO BEAT THEM.
I'M OUT.
I-I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE FEEDBACK.
OKAY, WHAT DO WE HAVE HERE?
ROBERT AND MR. CUBAN.
TWO TECH GUYS.
OKAY, PATRICK,
HERE'S -- HERE'S WHAT I SEE.
WE ALL HAVE TO SHRINK
OUR DIGITAL FOOTPRINT,
BUT THE GROWTH SIDE
OF YOUR BUSINESS, I THINK,
IS GOING TO REACH
A ROADBLOCK
AS THE TECHNOLOGY CHANGES
AND THE DEPENDENCY
ON SOCIAL MEDIA GROWS.
YET YOU DON'T KNOW HOW YOU'RE
GOING TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM,
BUT YOU'RE PRICING AS IF
YOU HAVE SOLVED THAT PROBLEM.
AND BECAUSE
OF THAT DISCONNECT,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
WELL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ROBERT?
MR. HERJAVEC, MR. SECURITY GUY.
PAT, I LIKE IT.
YOU KNOW, I -- I THINK
THAT, UH, THERE'S DEFINITELY
A BUSINESS HERE.
YEP.
I THINK THERE'S
A VERY LARGE BUSINESS
FOR CONSUMERS THAT MAY NOT
BE COMPUTER SAVVY,
THAT WANT A BETTER REPUTATION
OR GET RID OF SOMETHING.
YOUR REAL VALUE
IS YOUR GROWTH.
YEAH.
BUT THE VALUATION IS NUTS.
I MEAN, IT'S --
IT'S JUST NUTS.
I HEAR -- I HEAR YOU.
WHAT -- WHAT WOULD --
I MEAN, IT'S $15 MILLION,
$16 MILLION AT THIS POINT,
WHERE YOU'RE DOING A COUPLE
MILLION DOLLARS IN SALES.
BUT HERE'S THE BEAUTY
OF "SHARK TANK."
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO ASK
FOR WHATEVER YOU WANT.
YEP.
RIGHT?
YES.
AS A SHARK, I'M ALLOWED
TO OFFER WHATEVER I WANT.
HERE'S AN OFFER I FEEL
VERY COMFORTABLE WITH.
OKAY.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $2 MILLION
FOR 25%.
$2 MILLION, 25%.
WHAT IF WE DID SOMETHING --
BECAUSE OUT OF FAIRNESS
TO INVESTORS --
I AM A LITTLE BIT MORE LOCKED IN
BECAUSE OF FAIRNESS
OF WHAT WE'VE JUST CLOSED ON.
LOOK, I BELIEVE IN IT.
I THINK YOU'RE
A REALLY SMART GUY.
I THINK YOU'RE DOING IT.
I ALSO BELIEVE IT'S RISKY.
WE'LL DO $10 MILLION,
$15 MILLION BY 2015,
WHERE YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET
YOUR MONEY BACK --
PATRICK, HE JUST VALUED
YOUR BUSINESS AT $8 MILLION.
HE'S THE LARGEST INVESTOR
THAT'S EVER WRITTEN A CHECK.
PAT, I'M NOT INTER--
PAT, I AM NO --
AND HE'S A SHARK.
I LOVE IT WHEN HE DOES
MY TALKING FOR ME.
PAT,
I DON'T HAVE ANY INTEREST --
I'M TRYING TO HELP YOU.
CAN I --
BECAUSE CLEARLY YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
I DON'T HAVE ANY INTEREST
IN GETTING MY MONEY BACK
THIS YEAR, NEXT YEAR.
THIS IS YOU'RE EITHER
GONNA SCALE IT
TO $50 MILLION OR $100 MILLION
OR YOU'RE NOT.
DO YOU MIND
IF I GIVE SOMEONE A CALL
AND -- AND THINK ABOUT IT
FOR A SECOND?
I THINK
BAD THINGS CAN HAPPEN.
I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANYTHING IN BETWEEN.
I'M NOT GONNA WASTE
YOUR TIME.
I'M NOT
GONNA NEGOTIATE DOWN.
IT'S $2 MILLION FOR 25%.
YOU KNOW, ROBERT,
FOR 2 MILLION BUCKS,
IF YOU LIKE THIS BUSINESS
SO MUCH, JUST DO IT YOURSELF.
[ LAUGHS ]
HE COULD TRY.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
$2 MILLION, 25% --
I CAN'T ACCEPT IT.
BUT THAT $2 MILLION WOULD GO
A VERY LONG WAY.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE --
O'Leary: DON'T WORRY.
OF COURSE.
IT'LL GO A LONG WAY
FOR SOMEBODY ELSE
WHO'S GONNA GET IT
RIGHT AFTER YOU LEAVE.
I KNOW.
SO TURN AROUND, PLEASE.
TIME TO GIVE IT
TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
ALL RIGHT. WELL --
O'Leary: THANK YOU FOR COMING.
Ambron: GUYS, I --
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
[ SIGHS ]
HEY, THAT AGE,
TO TURN DOWN 2 MILLION BUCKS --
IT TAKES GUTS.
THAT WAS A DEAL I VISUALIZED.
I WANTED IT SO BAD.
BUT AT THE END, WE JUST COULDN'T
MEET IN THE MIDDLE,
AND I -- YOU KNOW,
SAYING NO WAS HARD,
BUT I-IT'S JUST WHAT I HAD
TO DO.
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A HIGH-TECH WAY
TO HELP YOU FEEL CONNECTED
TO YOUR PETS.
HI, SHARKS.
I'M JAMES PELLAND.
AND I'M BROOKE MARTIN.
AND THIS IS OUR FRIEND YOYO.
WE'RE ASKING YOU FOR
A $150,000 INVESTMENT
IN RETURN FOR 20%
IN OUR COMPANY, iCPooch.
iCPooch IS MERGING
THE TECH INDUSTRY
WITH THE PET INDUSTRY.
MY FAMILY DOG SUFFERED
FROM SEPARATION ANXIETY
WHENEVER WE LEFT HER ALONE
AT HOME.
SHE WOULD OFTEN BE DEPRESSED
OR EVEN DESTRUCTIVE,
AND IT WAS SO HEARTBREAKING
TO SEE HER SUFFER.
I DID A LOT OF RESEARCH,
AND I FOUND OUT THAT
CANINE SEPARATION ANXIETY
IS A COMMON PROBLEM
THAT AFFECTS
MORE THAN 10 MILLION DOGS
IN THE U.S. ALONE.
I THOUGHT IT'D BE GREAT
IF THERE WAS A WAY TO CHECK IN
ON MY DOG REMOTELY,
EASE HER LONELINESS,
AND MAYBE EVEN GIVE HER A TREAT.
SO I CREATED iCPooch,
A DEVICE THAT LETS YOU
TWO-WAY VIDEO CHAT WITH YOUR DOG
AND DELIVER THEM A TREAT
FROM ANYWHERE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
iCPooch IS EASY
TO SET UP.
JUST DOWNLOAD OUR FREE APP ON
YOUR SMARTPHONE OR SMART TABLET,
CONNECT iCPooch TO WI-FI,
YOU PLACE A DEVICE
ON THE FRONT OF iCPooch,
AND THEN SET IT IN
A CONVENIENT PLACE FOR YOUR PET.
YOYO'S OWNER, GLEN,
IS SO PROUD
THAT SHE GETS TO BE HERE TODAY
PITCHING
IN FRONT OF YOU SHARKS,
BUT HE MISSES YOYO TERRIBLY
AND WANTS TO CHECK IN
TO SEE HOW SHE'S DOING
HERE IN THE TANK.
ALL GLEN HAS TO DO IS LAUNCH
THE iCPooch APP ON HIS PHONE,
AND GLEN CAN SEE
AND SPEAK TO YOYO,
AND HIS FACE AND VOICE OFFERS
A CALMING REMINDER
THAT YOYO IS LOVED
AND MISSED.
[ LAUGHS ]
Hi, Yoyo.
COME SAY HI.
SETTLE.
Are you being a good girl
for the sharks?
IF HE WANTS TO SHOW
EVEN MORE LOVE,
HE CAN SIMPLY PRESS A BUTTON
AND iCPooch DISPENSES A TREAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
iCPooch IS THE NEXT BEST THING
TO ACTUALLY BEING WITH YOUR DOG.
SO, SHARKS,
WHICH ONE OF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO HELP REVOLUTIONIZE
THE WAY
WE INTERACT
WITH OUR BEST FRIENDS?
Greiner:
[ CHUCKLES ]
Herjavec: JAMES, WE HAVE VIDEO
CONFERENCING IN OUR BUSINESS.
I CAN'T GET HUMANS
TO USE VIDEO CONFERENCING
TO TALK TO EACH OTHER.
[ LAUGHS ]
WHAT MAKES YOU THINK
THAT DOGS,
ON A CONSISTENT BASIS,
ARE GONNA DO THAT?
WELL,
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
I WAS INVITED
TO A CONFERENCE
BY THE AMERICAN PROFESSIONAL
DOG TRAINERS ASSOCIATION,
AND ACTUALLY
A LOT OF DOG TRAINERS
ARE USING SKYPE TECHNOLOGIES
TO TRAIN DOGS.
WITHOUT A HUMAN PRESENCE,
THEY'RE ABLE TO --
BUT HOW DO I GET THE DOG TO SIT
AT THE KEYBOARD AND TYPE?
[ LAUGHTER ]
SKYPING TO THE DOGS, HUH?
IS YOUR PRODUCT JUST THE CASE?
'CAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S A STANDARD TABLET.
THAT'S CORRECT.
AND WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
RIGHT NOW,
IT'S $149 RETAIL.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE?
$60.
HAVE YOU SOLD ANY?
YES.
WE JUST STARTED SHIPPING PRODUCT
ABOUT TWO MONTHS AGO.
WE'VE SOLD SO FAR
ABOUT 115 UNITS.
115,000?
NO, 115 UNITS.
115.
MY GRAVEST CONCERN IS
YOU'RE INTRODUCING SOMETHING
THAT LOOKS LIKE A FIRE HYDRANT
RIGHT INTO SOMEBODY'S KITCHEN.
Cuban: [ LAUGHS ]
I'M JUST WONDERING
WHAT THE OUTCOME'S GONNA BE.
THAT'S A GREAT POINT,
KEVIN.
IT IS A GOOD POINT.
O'Leary:
WHAT STOPS POOCHY FROM SAYING,
"I'VE SEEN THAT BEFORE OUTSIDE.
I KNOW WHAT TO DO
ON MY OWNER'S FACE"?
Greiner: [ LAUGHS ]
SO, I HAVE A QUESTION.
HOW DID THE TWO OF YOU
COME UP WITH IT?
I CREATED THIS 12 --
WHEN I WAS 12.
I'M 14 NOW. UM --
WOW.
YOU'RE ONLY 14?
YES.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WOW.
I CAME UP WITH THIS IDEA,
AND I PITCHED IT AT AN EVENT
CALLED STARTUP WEEKEND,
AND SO IT WAS ME AND 39
OTHER ADULTS THAT HAD PITCHED,
AND I ENDED UP GETTING
THE MOST NUMBER OF VOTES,
SO I GOT TO WORK
WITH A TEAM OF PEOPLE --
DEVELOPERS, DESIGNERS.
WE THINK THAT DOGS
HAVE A LOT OF,
YOU KNOW, ANXIETY
WHEN THEIR OWNERS ARE AWAY,
AND THE OWNERS DO, TOO,
YOU KNOW?
THEY MISS THEIR DOGS
WHEN THEY'RE NOT ABLE
TO BE WITH THEM.
IS JAMES YOUR DAD,
BROOKE?
NO.
JAMES -- SO, WE MET JAMES,
UM, THROUGH SCHOOL.
HE -- HIS KIDS WENT TO SCHOOL
WITH ME AND MY LITTLE SISTER.
AND, SO, WE GOT TO KNOW HIM,
AND WITH HIS BACKGROUND --
AND WE BROUGHT HIM ON BOARD
AS THE C.E.O.
SO, JAMES,
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
I SPENT 11 YEARS
IN THE COMPUTER INDUSTRY
BETWEEN ASUS COMPUTERS,
DELL COMPUTERS,
AND GENERAL DYNAMICS.
IS THIS
YOUR FULL-TIME JOB NOW
OR ARE YOU STILL WORKING
FOR OTHER COMPANIES?
YES, IT IS. YES.
I LEFT ASUS TO COME DO THIS.
JAMES, HOW MUCH ARE YOU PAYING
YOURSELF TO RUN THE COMPANY?
NOTHING.
GOOD. OKAY.
PART OF WHAT WE HOPE
TO DO IS -- IS GET, UM,
FURTHER DOWN THE ROAD
WITH, UH, DESIGN.
HOWEVER, IN TERMS OF
THE FIRE HYDRANT,
WE HAVEN'T HAD
ANY REPORTS OF THAT,
AND NONE OF THE DOGS
WE'VE TESTED WITH
HAVE EVER DONE THAT.
ARE YOU IN RETAILERS ANYWHERE?
WE'RE ON AMAZON.
WE ARE ABOUT TO SHIP
OUR FIRST SHIPMENT,
AND WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT P.O. IS FOR YET,
TO BED BATH & BEYOND.
MM-HMM.
'CAUSE THEY'RE DOING
A PET TECH SORT OF THING,
AND THEY'RE DOING A TEST
IN ABOUT NINE STORES.
AND THEY DIDN'T TELL YOU
HOW MANY UNITS
THEY WERE GOING TO ORDER?
NO, THEY DIDN'T.
CAN WE SEE THE PRODUCT?
I WAS CURIOUS...
Herjavec: YOYO.
...'CAUSE YOU CALLED
THE DOG OVER.
[ SMOOCHES ]
THE DOG DIDN'T GO TO GLEN.
COME HERE.
DID YOU NOTICE THAT?
COME ON!
THE DOG --
THE HARD PART
ABOUT THIS IS
THERE'S SO MANY DISTRACTIONS
IN THIS SETTING.
Herjavec:
SHOW ME WHERE IT GETS --
THE TREAT COMES OUT
THE FRONT HERE.
AND HOW DOES THE TREAT
GET RELEASED?
IT'S KIND OF LIKE
A PEZ DISPENSER.
BASICALLY,
YOU STACK THE TREATS INSIDE.
OH, I SEE.
AND IT SWIPES THE BOTTOM ONE
OUT INTO THE TRAY,
AND THEN
THEY JUST FALL DOWN.
SO, IS THE THEORY
THAT YOU COME HOME
AND YOU TAKE THE iPad OFF
AND YOU USE IT NORMALLY?
YEAH. EXACTLY.
TO ME,
THAT'S THE BIGGEST PROBLEM.
BECAUSE NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE GONNA HAVE AN EXTRA iPad.
I THINK THE FACT
THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
AN EXTRA TABLET OF SOME SORT,
UM, REALLY LIMITS YOUR MARKET
TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE CAPABLE
OF AFFORDING THAT.
YOU KNOW, CONCEPTUALLY,
I THINK IT'S AN OKAY IDEA,
BUT I JUST THINK IT'S GONNA BE
HARD TO CONVEY IT
AND EXPENSIVE TO SELL,
AND FOR THOSE REASONS, I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OPINION.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
WE ARE LOOKING TO, UH,
DROP COST,
THUS DROP -- BE ABLE
TO DROP PRICE.
SO RIGHT NOW, THERE'S A LITTLE
OVER 30% MARGIN.
30% MARGIN, THOUGH,
I THINK IS LOW.
LIKE, MOST PLACES WANT
50% OR HIGHER.
YEAH, WE AGREE.
BUT EVERYBODY
WE'VE TALKED TO SO FAR,
THEY --
THEY'RE OKAY WITH 40%.
I THINK THE CONCEPT
IS A NICE CONCEPT,
AND I DO THINK IT'S PROBABLY
MORE COMFORTING
TO THE OWNER
THAN TO THE DOG.
ABSOLUTELY.
THAT IS WHERE I THINK
IT FALLS.
BUT I DON'T SEE IT BEING A GREAT
MARKET PRODUCT RIGHT NOW.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
O'Leary:
I HAVE A DIFFERENT OPINION
ABOUT THIS PRODUCT.
THERE'S AN OLD SAYING,
"ABSENCE MAKES THE HEART
GROW FONDER."
[ CHUCKLES ]
I THINK A LITTLE SELF TIME
FOR A DOG IS VERY IMPORTANT.
[ LAUGHS ]
MAKES HIM MISS YOU.
WHEN YOU COME HOME,
HIS TAIL IS WAGGING.
I HATE THIS VERY MUCH
AS AN IDEA.
VERY MUCH.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, KEVIN.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR OPINION.
SEE, BROOKE, THE GREAT THING
ABOUT KEVIN IS
HE'S MEAN TO ADULTS
AND CHILDREN THE SAME WAY.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I APPLAUD YOU.
AT YOUR AGE,
COMPETING AGAINST ADULTS
AND ACTUALLY WIN A COMPETITION
LIKE THAT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES WHEN
YOU LAUNCH A PRODUCT LIKE THAT,
JUST BECAUSE YOU THINK
IT'S A GOOD IDEA
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN THAT
THE MARKET'S GONNA ACCEPT IT.
ABSOLUTELY.
AND YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH SALES
WHERE I CAN COUNT ON THAT.
YOU KNOW, WHEN I DON'T KNOW
IF SOMETHING'S GONNA WORK,
I LIKE TO RELY ON SALES,
AND YOU CAN PROVE ME WRONG.
I DON'T THINK YOU'VE DONE THAT.
I'M OUT.
John: I DON'T THINK
IT'S TESTED ENOUGH,
AND I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT,
YOU KNOW, HONESTLY,
DOGS SLEEP 95% OF THE TIME
THAT THE OWNER'S NOT THERE,
AND I THINK THAT
IT'S GONNA CREATE MORE ANXIETY
HOPING THAT OWNER COMES
ONTO THAT SCREEN.
UM, I JUST DON'T THINK IT'S,
YOU KNOW,
ENOUGH PROOF RIGHT THERE
WHETHER IT WORKS OR NOT.
SO, UM, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, DAYMOND.
Pelland: THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, THE GREAT THING
ABOUT THIS, THOUGH,
IS YOU'RE 14 YEARS OLD,
AND YOU'VE ALREADY THOUGHT OF
ONE PRETTY CLEVER ITEM.
I CAN'T IMAGINE
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA DO
IN THE NEXT DOZEN YEARS.
BROOKE, AT THIS PACE, YOU'LL BE
THE QUEEN OF QVC IN FOUR YEARS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THANK YOU.
John: THANKS A LOT.
GOOD LUCK.
COME ON, YOYO.
[ DOG BARKING ]
Martin: YOU KNOW, THE SHARKS
MISSED A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
TO INVEST IN iCPooch,
BUT I KNOW THE NEXT TIME
THAT THEY'RE MISSING THEIR PETS,
THEY'RE GONNA WANT
TO BE A CUSTOMER, FOR SURE.
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A PRODUCT DESIGNED
TO HELP DECLARE YOUR HOME PRIDE.
SHARKS, MY NAME IS RYAN SHELL,
AND I NOW LIVE IN NEW YORK CITY.
I'M THE FOUNDER OF THE HOME T,
AND I'M HERE TODAY
ASKING FOR $250,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 5% EQUITY
IN MY COMPANY.
[ LAUGHS ]
Shell: DO ME A FAVOR.
THINK ABOUT HOME
FOR JUST A SECOND.
IT'S A PLACE YOU KNOW
LIKE THE BACK OF YOUR HAND.
IT'S A COMFORTABLE PLACE
WHERE MEMORIES ARE MADE.
AND, YOU KNOW, I'VE NOT
ALWAYS LIVED IN NEW YORK CITY,
AND I'VE BECOME ALL TOO FAMILIAR
WITH WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO MISS HOME.
I MISS THE PEOPLE, THE ACCENTS,
THE SWEET TEA,
AND DON'T EVEN GET ME STARTED
ON THE BARBECUE.
SIMPLY PUT, HOME IS A PLACE
THAT MAKES YOU HAPPY,
AND WHEN I'M IN NEW YORK CITY,
IT SEEMS LIKE ALMOST DAILY
I'LL BE WALKING AROUND,
MINDING MY OWN BUSINESS,
AND THEN OUT OF THE BLUE I HEAR,
"WHOO-HOO, TEXAS!"
AND I LOOK UP,
AND SOMEONE HAS SPOTTED
THE TEXAS HOME T
THAT I'M WEARING.
AND YOU CAN SEE THEM SMILING
FROM EAR TO EAR.
THE HOME T IS MADE IN THE USA,
AND WE'RE EXTREMELY PROUD
TO DONATE A PORTION OF PROFIT
TO CHARITY.
THE BRAND IS ENJOYED
BY CUSTOMERS
ALL ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
AND IN OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD.
AND I BROUGHT A PIECE OF HOME
HERE FOR YOU TODAY.
I HAVE A LITTLE CROATIA
FOR YOU RIGHT HERE.
OH.
WELL, I LIKE IT NOW.
Shell: THERE'S ILLINOIS
RIGHT THERE.
THANK YOU.
Herjavec: LOOK AT THAT!
O'Leary: THANK YOU.
Greiner:
WHAT'S YOURS, KEVIN?
MASSACHUSETTS.
Herjavec: RYAN, YOU HAVE
A T-SHIRT COMPANY
YOU'RE SAYING IS WORTH
$5 MILLION.
YES, SIR.
WHY IS IT WORTH
$5 MILLION?
SO, IN OUR FIRST 12 MONTHS,
WE DID $1.1 MILLION IN REVENUE.
WELL,
YOU JUST SHUT ME UP.
WHAT'D YOU MAKE ON THAT?
$540,000.
THAT'S AMAZING.
HOW MANY PEOPLE
IN THE BUSINESS?
UH, RIGHT NOW,
IT IS JUST ME.
WOW.
Herjavec: HOW MUCH DO YOU
SELL THEM FOR, RYAN?
SO, THE CREW NECK THAT
YOU'RE HOLDING IS $30.
Greiner:
SO, I HAVE A QUESTION.
I MEAN, I KNOW IT--
IT'S A SOFT T-SHIRT.
I GET THE COMFORTS OF HOME,
OR PEOPLE SAYING,
"WHOO-HOO, TEXAS," OR WHATEVER.
RIGHT.
WHY DO YOU THINK...
WHOO-HOO!
...THAT THIS HAS DONE
SO AMAZINGLY WELL?
I THINK EVERYONE CAN CONNECT
WITH HOME.
OR ARE YOU JUST GREAT
AT P.R.?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
Shell:
FROM A MARKETING STANDPOINT,
WE DID START
WITH A LOT OF DIGITAL,
AND, UH, MARKETING
IS MY BACKGROUND --
MARKETING
AND PUBLIC RELATIONS.
THERE YOU GO.
LET'S GET TO THAT STUFF.
AND THE LAST "JOB" I HAD
WAS AT A MAJOR AGENCY
IN -- IN NEW YORK CITY.
I MEAN, I'LL HAVE TO SAY
THAT I THINK
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
AN ENTREPRENEUR AT HEART
WHEN I WOULD SAY
I GREW UP
IN WHAT WOULD BE CATEGORIZED AS
A LOW-MIDDLE-CLASS FAMILY.
WHERE'D YOU GROW UP?
NORTH CAROLINA.
WHY IS TEXAS HOME?
IT'S OUR NUMBER-ONE
SELLING PRODUCT...
THERE YOU GO.
...AND I CONSTANTLY SELL
THIS SHIRT.
SO YOU'RE A FANTASTIC SALESMAN,
YOU'RE A GREAT MARKETER.
NOW I ASK MYSELF A QUESTION
THAT WE ALWAYS DEAL WITH
ON "SHARK TANK"
WHEN A COMMODITY
COMES FORWARD --
MM-HMM.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN PROTECT
ANY OF THIS.
SO I ASK MYSELF, "IF I REALLY
WANT TO COMPETE WITH YOU,
CAN I TAKE $5 MILLION,
GO HIRE ANOTHER RYAN,
AND SAY, 'LISTEN, GUY,
LET'S GO OUT THERE
AND KNOCK THIS OFF,
BECAUSE IT'S SO EASY
TO DO IT.'"
YOU'RE NOT WORTH $5 MILLION.
YOU CAN'T PROTECT ANY OF IT.
I'M ABSOLUTELY WORTH
$5 MILLION.
WHY?
AND IT'S ALL ABOUT
THE BRAND, KEVIN.
YOU CAN CREATE --
WHAT BRAND?
THE HOME T.
YOU MIGHT -- IT MIGHT --
WHY CAN'T I CALL IT
"THE MR. WONDERFUL HOME T"?
WAIT, STOP, STOP.
STOP!
RYAN, THE DIFFERENCE IS
THAT'S $5 MILLION TO RISK.
RIGHT.
YOU'RE PROFITABLE.
YOU'VE REDUCED THE RISK.
IT TAKES NOTHING
TO SET THIS UP!
SO YOU'RE WAY AHEAD.
IT TAKES YOU $5 MILLION.
NOTHING!
THE HOME T
IS A TRADEMARKED BRAND.
YOU CANNOT -- YOU CANNOT
PROTECT ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
WHEN YOU CAME OUT, RYAN,
HONESTLY, I THOUGHT,
"T-SHIRT WITH A COOL LOGO."
MM-HMM.
"IT'S INTERESTING."
NOT IN MY WILDEST DREAMS
DID I THINK YOU'D
BE MAKING $1 MILLION.
LOOK, I DIDN'T, EITHER.
HOW -- HOW ARE YOU KILLING IT?
HELP ME UNDERSTAND THAT.
SO, WORD OF MOUTH MARKETING
HAS BEEN MASSIVE FOR US WHEN --
HOW DID YOU
GET THAT STARTED?
YEAH, WHAT KIND OF
WORD OF MOUTH?
IT LITERALLY STARTED WITH,
YOU KNOW, YOU SELL A FEW SHIRTS,
AND THEN YOU BUY CROATIA,
AND THEN YOU PUT IT ON FACEBOOK,
AND THEN YOUR FRIENDS --
SO, BY PEOPLE SEEING IT?
SO, PEOPLE SEE IT --
SO IT'S JUST
A GRASSROOTS MOVEMENT.
IT HAS BEEN 100% GRASSROOTS.
WE'VE USED FACEBOOK
VERY EFFECTIVELY.
I KNOW, MARK, YOU MIGHT NOT --
HOW MANY LIKES
DO YOU HAVE ON FACEBOOK?
WE HAVE 56,000 LIKES
ON FACEBOOK.
SO, WHAT I USE THAT AUDIENCE FOR
IS NOT TO SAY,
"HEY, I'VE GOT
A BIG FACEBOOK AUDIENCE!"
RIGHT.
IT'S TO SAY,
"HERE'S A NEW PRODUCT."
I CAN ADVERTISE
DIRECTLY TO THAT GROUP.
RIGHT, BUT YOU
HAVE TO PAY FOR THAT.
AND I WANT TO KNOW HOW MUCH
DID YOU SPEND LAST YEAR
ON FACEBOOK ADVERTISING?
UH, I THINK IT WAS PROBABLY
LESS THAN $5,000.
WOW.
WE HAVE TWO ADS RIGHT NOW...
THAT'S NOT MUCH.
THAT ARE CONVERTING
FOR LESS THAN $5 AN AD.
OKAY,
SO THAT'S GOOD, RIGHT?
BUT I-I'M STILL NOT BUYING
THAT WORD OF MOUTH...
YEAH, I'M NOT
BUYING IT, EITHER.
...AND FACEBOOK ADS ARE IT.
BECAUSE YOU MENTIONED
A LOT ABOUT P.R.
YOU'RE FROM AN AGENCY.
RIGHT.
SO, IN ADDITION TO
THE WORD OF MOUTH,
WE'VE BEEN VERY FORTUNATE
WITH CELEBRITIES.
PEOPLE LIKE BRYAN CRANSTON
HAVE WORN THE PRODUCT,
WHICH IS,
I MEAN, SUPER COOL, RIGHT?
WELL, THAT'S HUGE.
AND HOW DO YOU
CONVERT THAT TO AN IMAGE?
YOU JUST PUT IT
ON YOUR WEBSITE?
Shell: CORRECT.
NOW, WE DID GET LUCKY
WITH HILARY DUFF.
SHE WORE THE SHIRT.
THEN IT LANDED IN US WEEKLY.
SO WHAT WAS YOUR BUMP IN SALES
FROM THAT?
WE TOTALED -- IT WAS MORE THAN
$200,000 IN REVENUE THAT MONTH.
OKAY.
ARE YOU SELLING
ALMOST ALL ONLINE
OR ARE YOU SELLING
THROUGH RETAILERS?
WE SELL A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
DIRECTLY VIA OUR WEBSITE.
WELL, IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU HAVE BAGS...
RIGHT.
...YOU HAVE HATS.
IS THAT A PILLOW?
YES.
WE SELL THE HATS,
WE'VE GOT THE TOTE BAGS.
HOW MUCH OF THE NON-T-SHIRT
STUFF DO YOU SELL?
COLLECTIVELY LESS THAN 10%.
THIS YEAR, YOU MADE $1 MILLION.
WHY ARE YOU HERE?
I NEED TO HIRE SOME PEOPLE.
FIRST OFF, ON THE 5% --
THAT IS A STARTING POINT
FOR A NEGOTIATION.
I KNOW YOU GUYS
JUST LOVE 5%, SO --
NO, WE ACTUALLY HATE IT.
YEAH, NO, I-I TOTALLY KNOW.
UM, YOU'RE A VERY
SMART GUY.
[ CHUCKLES ]
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN US
TAKE A DEAL FOR 5%?
AS I SAID,
5% WAS A STARTING POINT,
AND WE CAN MOVE FROM THERE
IF NEED BE.
O'Leary: [ LAUGHS ]
LISTEN, RYAN, I-I-I'LL HELP
EVERYBODY OUT HERE.
T-SHIRTS ARE A COMMODITY,
OKAY?
THEY'RE JUST
A TOTAL COMMODITY.
YOU ARE A BRILLIANT MARKETER.
I'M GONNA HAND YOU THAT.
BRILLIANT.
AND AN EVEN BETTER
SALESPERSON.
BUT TO ME, THERE IS NO CHANCE
IN T-SHIRT HELL
THAT THIS IS WORTH
$5 MILLION,
BECAUSE EVEN THE EXISTING
ONLINE PLAYERS,
OF WHICH THERE ARE MANY,
CAN ACTUALLY DO THAT,
AND THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN DO
TO STOP THEM.
I'M NOT SAYING
YOU HAVEN'T DONE
A GREAT JOB IN CREATING
DEMAND FOR THIS,
BUT THERE'S NOTHING PROPRIETARY
ABOUT IT,
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING PROTECTABLE.
NO WAY IN HELL
IT'S WORTH 5 MILLION BUCKS.
SIR, YOU'RE WEARING A SUIT.
I'M SELLING T-SHIRTS.
I WEAR T-SHIRTS
ALL WEEKEND LONG.
I'VE NEVER SEEN YOU
IN A T-SHIRT.
IT DOESN'T MEAN
YOU PLAY IN THE CIRCLE.
OH!
HE JUST DISSED YOU.
WOW, RYAN!
[ LAUGHS ]
O'Leary:
YOU CAN SAY WHATEVER YOU WANT.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY HERE --
AND, YOU KNOW,
YOU CAN BE BRAVADO
AND SAY WHATEVER YOU LIKE --
IS GOING TO GIVE YOU
$250,000 FOR 5%,
BECAUSE I LIVE
ON THE PLANET EARTH,
AND I KNOW WHAT
A T-SHIRT COMPANY'S WORTH.
I'M OUT.
John:
COMING IN HERE, 5% --
YOU DIDN'T REALLY WANT A DEAL,
I DON'T BELIEVE.
I ABSOLUTELY WANTED A DEAL,
AND AS I STATED,
IT IS A STARTING POINT.
THEN WHY NOT ASK
FOR A REALISTIC AMOUNT?
NO, HE -- HE CAME IN AND SAID
HE'S GONNA NEGOTIATE.
THAT'S FAIR.
I WAS VERY OPEN WITH THAT.
AS OPPOSED TO SAYING
HE'S NOT GOING TO NEGOTIATE.
SO, LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION.
WHAT WOULD YOU GO UP?
I THINK 10%, 15%
IS SOMETHING THAT I FEEL
PRETTY COMFORTABLE WITH,
AND BEYOND THAT,
I THINK IT'S JUST NEGOTIATION.
OKAY, SO, I DON'T REALLY BELIEVE
THAT YOU WANT A DEAL, AND, UM...
IT'S JUST MY GUT FEELING.
I'M OUT.
I'M SITTING HERE
TELLING YOU GUYS
I GENUINELY WOULD LOVE A DEAL.
YOU KNOW, I -- LOOK,
ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE
ALL VERY AWARE OF
IS WHAT WE CALL
THE GOLD DIGGERS, RIGHT?
SOMEONE COMING IN
NOT REALLY LOOKING FOR A DEAL,
JUST LOOKING FOR THE P.R.
ABSOLUTELY.
I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE A GOLD DIGGER.
I THINK YOU HAVE
REAL REASONS TO BE HERE.
MY QUESTION IS
WHAT COMES NEXT?
THERE'S GOT TO BE MORE TO IT
TO BE A SUSTAINABLE COMPANY.
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY MORE.
THE -- THE AMAZING THING,
AND WHAT IS BLOWING MY MIND,
IS THE SUSTAINABILITY OF
THIS DESIGN IN AND OF ITSELF.
SO IT'S BEEN 24 MONTHS.
THIS SHIRT CONTINUES TO SELL.
HAVE YOU TRIED SELLING
IN ANY LARGE RETAILERS?
WE'VE NOT GONE AFTER ANYTHING,
AND, YOU KNOW, QUITE FRANKLY,
JUST WITH JUST ME --
DO YOU DO TRADE SHOWS
OR ANYTHING?
DO A FEW TRADE SHOWS,
AND THAT HELPS BRING IN
SOME NEW ACCOUNTS.
John: YOU BETTER --
YOU BETTER STOP THE WHOLESALE
AND DO EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE DOING,
BECAUSE IN ABOUT TWO,
THREE YEARS,
ALL THE "I LOVE NEW YORK"
COMPANIES
AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE,
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE THIS
IN EVERY SOUVENIR SHOP
ALL OVER THE PLACE,
SO YOU SHOULD JUST
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT,
TAKE THE MONEY AND RUN.
AND, REALLY, RYAN, I --
CONGRATULATIONS.
I THINK YOU'VE DONE
A GREAT JOB.
YOU'RE DOING A GREAT JOB.
TAKE THE MONEY AND RUN.
THE HARD PART OF THIS IS
GOING FROM A PRODUCT
TO A REAL COMPANY, RIGHT?
I THINK WE'VE DEVELOPED A BRAND.
YOU -- YOU HAVEN'T
DEVELOPED A BRAND.
YOU'VE DEVELOPED
A VERY CONVINCING PRODUCT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MAKE IT
AN INVESTABLE COMPANY.
EVERY SINGLE GREAT PRODUCT
THAT'S EVER COME OUT
IN THE CLOTHING WORLD
HAS SEEN A POINT
WHERE IT WAS HERE...
RIGHT.
AND THEN IT GOT DOWN HERE.
THE BRILLIANT COMPANIES,
THE SUPER SUCCESSFUL COMPANIES,
ARE SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY DO
WHEN IT STARTS TO DIP,
RIGHT?
I JUST DON'T SEE WHAT YOU'RE
GONNA DO WHEN THAT TIME COMES.
I HAVE CUSTOMERS THAT ARE DYING
FOR OTHER COLORS.
I HAVE E-MAILS DAILY.
RYAN.
RYAN, THAT'S GREAT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MAKE IT
A LONG-TERM COMPANY.
AND AS AN INVESTOR,
THAT'S WHAT I NEED TO SEE,
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
RYAN, YOUR COMPANY'S ON FIRE.
IT'S FANTASTIC.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHY YOU'RE KILLING IT.
YOUR SALES ARE REMARKABLE
FOR A T-SHIRT.
BUT THERE IS A LOT AT RISK
IN THE CLOTHING BUSINESS.
IT'S GONNA DIP.
THE HIGHS ARE HIGH,
AND THE LOWS ARE LOW.
SO, YOU GOT TO BUILD IN
SOME RISK.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
$250,000 FOR 35%.
ANY THOUGHTS FROM YOU, LORI?
AND THANK YOU FOR THE OFFER.
WHAT IF I GAVE YOU
$250,000 FOR 30%?
I W-- SO LET'S --
LET'S HYPOTHETICALLY SAY --
JUST DO THE MATH, RIGHT?
JUST DO THE MATH.
THAT'S LESS --
THAT'S LESS
THAN I'M MAKING THIS YEAR.
I WOULD BE SAYING,
"HERE'S THE COMPANY.
I'M WILLING IT AWAY."
I WOULD WANT TO DO A FAIR DEAL
WITH YOU GUYS, AND 30% OR 35% --
RYAN, YOU CAME OUT
LOOKING FOR 5%.
YOU,
BY YOUR OWN ADMISSION --
O'Leary: RYAN.
Greiner: BUT YOU SAID
THAT YOU --
IT WAS A STARTING POINT --
YOU DON'T WALK OUT HERE
TO BE STUPID.
O'Leary: YOU HAVE TWO OFFERS.
YOU'RE SMART, RYAN.
STICK TO YOUR GUNS.
YOU HAVE TWO OFFERS.
YOU GOT ONE
FOR 30% AND $250,000,
AND THE OTHER 35% --
DON'T TURN STUPID ON US,
RYAN.
FOCUS ON THOSE.
NOW YOU FOUND OUT
THE REAL MARKET VALUE.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S THE REAL MARKET VALUE,
AND NO INSULT TO THE OFFERS.
YOU JUST HEARD TWO OFFERS!
I COULD ENTERTAIN SOMETHING
IN THE 10% RANGE,
AND HAPPY TO DISCUSS THAT.
IN THE 10% RANGE?
10%, 15%.
I'M JUST OPENING THE DOOR.
Herjavec: RYAN. RYAN.
IN THE 10% RANGE, I'M TAKING
MY MONEY AND GOING HOME.
I'M OUT.
RYAN, YOU HAVE AN OFFER.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
I'M SORRY.
I CA-- I-I WOULD LOVE
TO PARTNER WITH YOU,
BUT I JUST CAN'T DO THAT MUCH.
WHAT'S YOUR COUNTER?
WE COULD DO 10% AND $400,000.
OH.
OH, MY GOSH.
OH!
OH, YOU'RE RAISING
THE MONEY, TOO.
I FORBID YOU
TO DO THAT DEAL.
IT'S A $4 MILLION VALUATION.
IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE --
NO, I'M SORRY.
IT'S A T-SHIRT COMPANY!
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
OKAY.
PHEW.
RYAN, I'LL GIVE YOU $250,000
FOR 20%.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
O'Leary: OKAY.
PHEW.
RYAN, I'LL GIVE YOU $250,000
FOR 20%.
I'M -- I'M SORRY.
IT'S JUST --
YOU DIDN'T WANT A DEAL THEN,
LIKE I THOUGHT.
Cuban: YEAH, HE DID.
SEE, I DON'T AGREE
WITH THAT, RYAN.
DON'T -- DON'T -- DON'T GET
BUMMED OUT ABOUT THAT.
ENOUGH.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT OFFER?
I APPRECIATE THE OFFER,
BUT IT'S JUST --
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW IT --
THAT'S A MILLION DOLLARS YOU'RE
SAYING THE COMPANY'S WORTH.
I'M MAKING MORE THAN THAT
THIS YEAR.
JUST -- YOU'RE RIGHT.
YOU REALLY ARE.
YOU MADE YOUR CHOICES.
NO, HE'S NOT, MARK.
YES, HE IS. HE'S RIGHT.
NO, HE'S NOT.
WELL, THEN, EITHER THAT,
OR HE'S ONE HELL OF A LIAR.
EITHER THAT OR HE'S A LIAR
'CAUSE HE'S GIVING YOU --
John: I GAVE YOU --
YOU'RE OUT OF YOUR MIND.
20% FOR $250,000 --
THAT'S WORTH MY TIME,
AS WELL.
THAT -- THAT'S ONE TIME
HE'S STUPID.
HE'S NOT HERE FOR A DEAL.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
HE WOULD BE --
HE WOULD BE
THE MORON OF THE CENTURY
IF HE SOLD $1 MILLION
IN SALES
AT A MILLION-DOLLAR
VALUATION.
YOU WANT TO STEP OVER DOLLARS
TO SAVE PENNIES,
THAT'S UP TO YOU.
I'M IN THE SAME EXACT INDUSTRY
AS YOU.
YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT I DON'T
DESERVE 1/5 OF THE COMPANY
TO BUST MY BUTT
AND MAKE IT A BIGGER COMPANY?
SO, I HAVE ALWAYS
BUSTED MY BUTT.
I'M NOT SAYING, "DAYMOND,
COME WORK FOR ME FULL TIME."
YOU OPEN SOME DOORS,
THROW SOME BREAD CRUMBS.
I'M HAPPY TO CHASE IT.
I'M NOT HERE TO OPEN DOORS
AND THROW BREAD CRUMBS.
I'M HERE
TO BE A PARTNER WITH YOU.
I-I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU COMING BACK IN,
BUT AT $1 MILLION,
I'M GONNA MAKE MORE THAN THAT
IN THIS 12-MONTH PERIOD.
AND I -- WELL,
LIKE MY FRIEND ALWAYS SAYS,
"YOU'RE DEAD TO ME, TOO."
THANK YOU. WELL, I HOPE
YOU ENJOY YOUR T-SHIRTS.
Cuban: GOOD LUCK, RYAN.
CONGRATULATIONS, RYAN.
GOOD LUCK.
THAT WAS WEIRD, DAYMOND.
NO, IT'S NOT.
HE'S NOT THAT STUPID.
SOMETHING'S WRONG.
YOU DON'T SELL
A MILLION DOLLARS IN EARNING
IN THE CURRENT YEAR
FOR A MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT MILLION DOLLARS
IS PAPER THIN -- PAPER THIN.
BUT IT'S STILL SPENDABLE.
PAPER THIN.
TOTAL COMMODITY.
IT'S A T-SHIRT.
Shell: THAT WENT MUCH DIFFERENT
THAN I THOUGHT.
MAYBE I SHOULD HAVE COME IN
AT HIGHER THAN 5%.
MAYBE I JUST COMPLETELY
SCREWED THAT UP.
I-I DON'T KNOW.